is communication any kind of detection
and if so
what do aliens look like as you get more
and more overlap on the cause of gravity
you're assuming let's assume
that so when you see them when they see
you
you're assuming they have vision they
have the ability to construct in 3d and
in time there's a lot of assumptions
we're making what detection all right
let's step back so yes okay you're right
so when in the english language when we
say the word see we mean visually they
show up to a party and it's like oh wow
that's an alien that's visual that's 3d
that's
okay
and that's also assuming scale
spatial scale of something that's
visible to you so it can't be
microscopic or it can't be so big that
you don't even realize that's an entity
okay um but other kinds of detection too
i would make it more abstract and go
down i was thinking this morning about
how to rewrite the arecibo message in
assembly theory and also to abandon
binary because i don't think aliens
necessarily why should they have binary
well they have some basic elements with
which to to do information exchange
make it more
fundamental more universal so we need to
think about what is the universal way of
making a memory and then we should
re-encode our sibo in that way
what's more basic than zeros and ones
well it's really difficult to get out
that causal chain because we're so let's
erase the idea of zero for a moment it
took human beings a long time to come up
with the idea of zero now now you've got
the idea of zero you can't throw it away
it's so useful to discover the idea yeah
to discover invent i don't know but it
took a long time so it was
invented that's right yeah i think zero
was invented it's exactly so it's not a
given that aliens know what zero is
that's that's the one massive assumption
it's a useful it's a useful discovery
that you're saying if you break the
causal chain there might be some other
more efficient way of representing why i
want to meet him and ask him
for a shortcut but you won't be able to
um ask him until what so i i interrupted
you and i think you're making a good
point i was just going to say well look
thank you
sorry
rather than saying he's internet tweet
at him for the rude interruptions i'll
go ahead i'm sorry no it's okay um maybe
it's change how do we so
oh i don't know what it's like to be an
alien i would like to know
you